somos libres para elegir o tenemos un
destino que nos determina
es una pregunta que me vengo haciendo ya
hace muchos años por un lado todos
tenemos un cuerpo sangre un sistema
nervioso el cerebro todos pertenecemos a
la raza humana
por otro lado cada uno hace su vida hace
lo que quiere toma sus decisiones y
construye su propia vida podríamos decir
que por un lado
estamos determinados por nuestra
estructura biológica y por el otro
también contamos con libertad con libre
albedrío durante toda nuestra existencia
desde chiquito siempre me gustó viajar
conocer mundos meterme en diferentes
culturas comunidades
después de terminar el secundario que
estudie un año en programación un poco
por mandato y un poco por elección
decidí irme de viajes me fui israel
vivía ahí tres años tuve la fortuna
también de ponerme en contacto con una
de mis pasiones que es el escribir
estudiando cine y televisión en la
universidad estaba pasando muy bien
hasta que de vuelta el destino un poco
me puso en contacto con esta sensación
de guerra que se vive allá y la verdad
que no me gustó y decidí irme también me
fui entonces a vivir a estados unidos
pasé un tiempo ahí y pasé por mi propio
cuerpo esto de la
ambición esas ganas de todo el tiempo
estar queriendo generar más queriendo
hacer más queriendo tener más en ese
mundo capitalista salvaje en el cual de
verdad era muy bueno me fue muy bien y
durante unos años me empecé a dar cuenta
que no era lo que realmente quería no
era lo que realmente me llenaba
decidí entonces irme de vuelta y me
viene argentina estuve un par de años
eche raíces me abrí un negocio
y mal quiere una casa y bueno y todavía
mantenía ese estilo de vida donde
realmente quería generar más hacer hacer
hacer hacer
y ahí el destino de vuelta me encontró
con un cachetazo perdí a alguien muy
cercano y me puse a pensar no esto como
la pérdida de alguna manera nos abre el
espacio para reinventarnos
me replanteé muchísimo de mi vida
muchísimo de mi sistema de valores lo
que quería hacer de la vida
decidí cambiar
y empecé a estudiar psicología para
entender muy bien cómo es que pensamos
porque hacemos lo que hacemos pero
también desde donde hacemos lo que
hacemos
en ese momento me puse también en
contacto con otra filosofía de vida que
ya varias personas estuvieron contando
un poco que tiene que ver en quechua se
dice suma qamaña y quiere decir el vivir
bien esa manera de vivir en armonía con
el entorno con la gente en donde lo que
buscamos es bienestar no vivir mejor lo
mejor que quiere lo mejor que qué
y entonces cambiar mi entorno ya
habiendo vivido en varios capitales del
mundo como también lo es buenos aires
que es una ciudad donde todo el tiempo
hay un ritmo que nos propone estar
haciendo haciendo haciendo realmente es
muy fácil estar haciendo algo en una
ciudad tan grande ahora es mucho más
difícil prestarle atención a quiénes
somos aquí a quién queremos ser y no
tanto el hacer
me fui a vivir a córdoba tras la sierra
la montaña en donde
decidió ocuparme de mí mismo y ahí
empecé también a viajar a la india
yendo y viniendo yendo y viniendo el
destino también me puso enfrente al
regalo más lindo que me hizo el universo
que es la meditación
de alguna manera elegí caminar ese
recorrido que con esfuerzo con
dedicación me di cuenta de que me hice
dueño de mi propia existencia aprendí a
respirar aprendí a comer aprendí a
hablar aprendí a caminar y a darme
cuenta de cada una de las cosas que hago
con conciencia
les voy a compartir dos episodios que
tuve en india que un poco explican que
estoy haciendo acá el primero estaba en
una barbería no sé si alguien ha ido
pero bueno estaba en una barbería esa es
donde hay un indio que te masajea la
cara todo de color rosa celeste y de
pronto entra un rabino ortodoxo y por la
puerta veo pasar una vaca india dio
en eso hablando un poco de la vida
termine conversando sobre la palabra
responsabilidad y la etimología de esta
palabra en hebreo se dice a riot en el
hebreo cada cada letra significa algo y
cuando se van sumando letras en la misma
palabra bueno en medio complejo pero se
los trató de simplificar
empieza con la primera letra del
abecedario que es la alef y quiere decir
yo de alguna manera me hago yo primero
responsable de mí mismo que es una tarea
dificilísima durante toda la vida no
después la segunda letra ya forma la
palabra que quiere decir a hermano ay me
hago responsable después de que me hice
responsable de mí de mis hermanos la
gente que me rodea la gente que conozco
que está a mi alrededor como en el avión
que primero te dicen baja la máscara de
oxígeno a veces lo pongo de al lado
el tercero ya es ayer qué quiere decir
el otro toda la gente que no conozco que
viene después la gente que está en mi
ciudad en mi comunidad en mi país o en
el mundo después viene la cuarta letra y
hace a harel viajar hay que decir
después que viene después del otro que
viene después de que ya realmente me sé
responsable de la gente que no conozco
es otro rol el rol de liderar el de
ponerse al frente el de orientar el de
marcar un camino siendo el ejemplo y
después se forma la palabra creencia que
tiene que ver con esto que una vez que
yo soy líder digamos no puedo estar
controlando al que hace cada uno que
viene atrás sino que tengo que crear
tengo que tener fe de que cada uno puede
elegir por sí mismo y marcar su propio
camino y ahí se completa la palabra
ajayu con la última letra del abecedario
que es la taf y se dice que uno es
responsable de la a la z
no hay no hay grises y me quedo muy bien
la barba también después de eso
el otro episodio fue unos días después y
estaba en un café en el mercado central
de nueva delhi fue sentado y se me
sienta al lado una persona de eeuu de
unos 50 y 60 años resultó que era el
responsable que era un arquitecto
digamos y que era el que la persona que
levantaba las minas de extracción de
minerales de las que están hechos las
laptop los celulares todas estas cosas
pero también hacía esos lugares a dónde
van los desechos de esos productos
después esta persona se codeaba con
gente muy poderosa porque lo hacía en
todo el mundo y también hablaba con la
gente que trabaja en las minas y me dijo
algo que simplemente dow muy grabado
mejor para que nosotros dos estemos acá
tomando un cafecito ahí abajo señalando
uno de los lugares más pobres
vulnerables miserables de la india hay
gente que tiene que estar muriéndose
el lado que no sabía qué decirle y sentí
que en el fondo tenía sentido lo que me
decía
eso también me despertó esto que hay una
enorme desigualdad de posibilidades en
el mundo que no siempre elegimos y que a
veces nos toca pero que sí nos convierte
a cada uno de nosotros en potenciales
agentes de cambio eso también me hizo
preguntar qué estoy haciendo yo desde
donde hago lo que hago y qué voy a hacer
unos años después terminé la carrera de
psicología y estaba de vuelta el destino
me encontró en el casamiento de mi
hermano que él se estaba haciendo cargo
por el mismo
con dos amigos de la infancia de que
tengo tres años los conozco que uno es
nicolás y el otro es cristiano al
empezar a hablar me di cuenta de que
cada uno también estaba ya haciéndose
cargo de su vida sabían lo que hacían de
qué manera y que querían niko es
ingeniero en biomedicina
le encanta la salud mental diagnóstico
predictivo tecnología y venía ya
investigando con realidad virtual y con
fobias cristian vivía en méxico y es
innovador social
y venía trabajando con un proyecto en
realidad virtual para la reforestación
de los corales mesoamericanos de playa
del carmen tulum un proyecto de alcance
global
básicamente después de conversar nos
dimos cuenta de que podíamos hacer algo
entre los tres y que no solo era mi vida
ni la de él ni la del otro sino entre
los tres para impactar más fuerte
decidimos entonces combinar nuestros
conocimientos nuestras experiencias de
vida nuestras redes pero por sobre todo
nuestro tiempo para aventurarnos en un
proyecto de vida que pudiese ayudar a la
mayor cantidad de gente desde la salud y
para con la accesibilidad
ahora nos preguntamos
vamos a un kiosco y encontramos ahí
miles de cosas entre ellas podemos
encontrar caja de cigarrillos que ya
dice te estoy matando de alguna manera
y eso quiere decir que el problema está
realmente al alcance de la mano está
completamente accesible dijimos cómo
puede ser que no existe una solución
completamente con el mismo rótulo con el
de accesibilidad como puede ser que la
misma sociedad en la que vivimos
promueve productos
efectivamente diseñados para que se
aprovechen de nuestra biología como
seres humanos
es libre la persona que empieza que va a
compra y después puede salir porque se
llamará adicción qué pasa con la idea de
democracia que cada uno es libre de
hacer lo que quiere mientras no daño el
tercero en realidad lo que va haciendo
va aumentando la brecha social la
desigualdad la inequidad
una de la uno de los síntomas más
digamos aterradores de esta forma de ver
el mundo de que alguien quiera más que
el otro quiere hacer más quiero vivir
mejor que el otro es el resultado es
siete millones de personas al año que se
mueren en todo el mundo a causa del
consumo de tabaco
para ponerlo en perspectiva es como si
de acá a dos años absolutamente toda la
gente que vive en capital federal
muriese 2020 toda la gente que vive no
conocen a nadie porque es todo entonces
nos preguntamos para qué
básicamente entendimos que para poder
lograr impactar en mil millones de
fumadores en el mundo
no sólo tenemos que pensar en redes sino
que también teníamos que actuar en redes
por eso empezamos a asociarnos de manera
colaborativa con universidades con
instituciones de salud de meditación
productores de realidad virtual escuela
de arte corporaciones multinacionales y
cientos de profesionales alrededor del
mundo que querían y quieren construir un
presente saludable un presente en donde
se viva de manera armónica y no mejor
así es como emprendimos un viaje nos
fuimos los tres dejamos todo lo que
teníamos y conscientemente elegimos
irnos al festival de innovación
tecnológica más grande en estados unidos
en donde de vuelta el destino y también
un poco por el empuje que tenemos nos
encontró con una persona que confía en
nosotros y nos llevó al silicon valley
esta meca de la tecnología del mundo en
donde al poco tiempo estábamos
conversando con mentores de google que
nos estaban mostrando un camino en el
cual podíamos impactar el nivel global
con una idea y cómo llevar esta idea un
proyecto pero por sobre todo llevarle a
la gente de cada una de las personas
lo que nosotros hacemos es un
tratamiento remoto que utiliza el
celular que cada uno tiene un celular
seguramente con lo que es realidad
virtual como las que ven afuera pero
esta es de cartón
es buena bonito y barato
eso acá se abre se pone el celular acá
adentro y uno ya puede tener lo que es
una experiencia inmersiva la realidad
virtual tiene como característica de que
nuestro sistema nervioso nuestra
biología no distingue si lo que vemos
acá es verdad o no es lo mismo que los
sueños es lo mismo que la hipnosis
combinamos mindfulness que es meditación
guiada con psicología terapias
cognitivo-conductuales y de esa manera
le damos a la persona la posibilidad de
que pueda conocerse a sí misma en
situaciones que les son familiares que
de pronto está desayunando con un café y
tiene ganas de fumar que está terminando
de comer con la familia y tiene ganas de
fumar que está subiendo las escaleras de
empezó a toser y tiene ganas de fumar
básicamente lo ponemos en contacto con
las ganas con eso que aparece con ese
impulso con eso que actuamos en piloto
automático y reaccionamos y lo que
hacemos es promover
respuestas creativas promover respuestas
con ausencia de juicio que no se juzgue
con compasión de manera tal que pueda
hacerle frente a los momentos que le dan
esas ganas
hoy en día estamos en un proceso
continuo de investigación y desarrollo
de una aplicación móvil
que tiene un diseño gámiz fika 2 esto
quiere decir que es un juego se juega
aprender y una persona puede aprender de
sí mismo para toda la vida entonces la
idea que nosotros tenemos es que vaya
pasando por diferentes situaciones hasta
que pueda empoderarse y pueda elegir por
sí misma puede salir de ese destino que
parece ser que se lo propone no no lo
sabemos
josé luís de 50 años juan manuel de 30 o
georgina de 60 son gentes que tienen
diferentes edades diferentes vidas pero
todos están unidos por una misma
intención que es la de querer cambiar
una manera de vivir nosotros formamos
una comunidad de gente que quiere
cambiar y que entre ellos forman su
propio ritmo van organizándose se
alientan entre sí
y también frenando le damos una puerta
de entrenamiento de la mente en donde
pueden causar pueden estar diez minutos
por día poniéndose en contacto con su
cuerpo su respiración sus sensaciones
pero en relación a una problemática que
quieren resolver ahora cambiar no es
fácil no incluso posiblemente gente que
esté acá piensa que la gente no cambia
imagínense qué difícil que es que la
misma cultura en la que vivimos cuando
somos chiquitos vemos que viene el nene
que está aprendiendo a caminar se golpea
con la mesa y viene el papá y le dice
mesa mala mesa mala como si la culpa
esto es la mesa imagínense qué difícil
que es responsabilizarnos entonces
nosotros
entendemos que para que exista
democratización en salud quiere decir
que sea accesible que haya una
herramienta accesible hay que hacer no
no tenemos que hacer una herramienta que
le resuelva la vida a la gente tenemos
que hacer una herramienta que le ayude a
la gente a resolver sus vidas por ellos
mismos y así es como nosotros vemos y
utilizamos la tecnología como
potenciadora de esta respuesta la
realidad virtual nos permite
concentrarnos en dónde estamos quiénes
somos para afuera eso quiere decir que
entender podemos entender cómo nos
relacionamos con la gente que nos rodea
a la gente que amamos y la que no amamos
el lugar en donde estamos y siempre
entendiendo cómo podemos mantener una
relación de convivencia y de armonía
las adicciones
se reflejan un poco también en esta
pregunta que yo me hice hace un tiempo
si somos libres o si estamos
determinados por algo y la verdad es que
después de mucho tiempo de mi vida
también me fui dando cuenta que la
felicidad no está en el tener no está en
lo material la felicidad está en como yo
me relaciono en la cualidad de las
relaciones que yo tengo con la gente con
el lugar en donde vivo
por eso es muy importante el hecho de
que cuando una persona sufre de una
adicción legal que puede ser al tabaco
puede ser el consumo de alcohol a los
azúcares
la persona se termina encerrando a sí
misma se termina sintiendo culpable por
lo que hace que siente vergüenza por
quienes no solo por lo que está haciendo
y que sabe quizás o no que lo hace sino
más que todo por la mirada de cada uno
de nosotros que emitimos frente a esa
persona es mucho más fácil el con el
dedito para afuera que con el dedito
para adentro esa persona
no es la única responsable de lo que le
pasa esto es un problema mucho más
complejos por eso estoy convencido de
que todos somos corresponsables a mí la
vida me enseñó que si cambiamos y
primero cambiamos yo acá yo cambio y por
el mismo efecto de la red
ese cambio llega a los demás muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]